pour sauver la planète je dois éradiquer
l'humanité c'est votre plan comment
allez-vous faire 8 milliards de
personnes c'est beaucoup quand même la
science a peut-être une solution
exploser toutes les bombes sur terre
Hiroshima Nagasaki 220 000 victimes avec
seulement de bons ça représentait
0,001 % de la population mondiale au
sommet de la guerre froide on avait 70
000 têtes nucléaires a considérer
pouvoir faire autant qu'au Japon on
serait à 8 milliards de morts potentiels
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup réduit
ce stock 13000 bombes principalement
entre la Russie et les États-Unis le
problème c'est qu'elles sont beaucoup
plus puissantes qu'avant Hiroshima
c'était 0,015 méga tonnes la Tsar Bomba
qui a explosé en 1961 50 méga tonnes 333
Hiroshima de quoi raser 15 fois la ville
de Paris et faire 7 millions de morts et
encore elle n'était pas à pleine
puissance en remplaçant le coeur en
plomb par un cœur d'uranium on aurait pu
doubler puissance malheureusement
impossible de savoir la puissance des
bombes qu'on les différents états on
sait que les USA n'utilisent plus de
bombes dites excessives le maximum en
service et la B83 jusqu'à 1,2 méga
tonnes la plupart des missiles
intercontinentaux tournent autour de 0,3
mais il y a de plus en plus de
nucléaires tactique on peut lancer
depuis un avion et qui sont destinés à
détruire des regroupements de chars ou
de navires de toutes petites explosions
équivalentes à celle d'Hiroshima on peut
donc estimer la moyenne des armes
déployées autour de 0,1 méga tonnes avec
le 13000 ogives dans le monde ça donne
1200 mégatonnes prêtes à exploser
comment les utiliser pour anéantir
l'humanité notre objectif c'est de faire
le plus de morts possible on va donc
viser les grandes villes 16 mégatonnes
suffisent à détruire Paris pour une
immense ville comme Shanghai on va
devoir monter à 95 ça permettrait
d'éradiquer 550 grandes villes soit 2
milliards de personnes
bien mais pas suffisant parce que 44% de
la population mondiale vit en zone
rurale 16% dans des petites villes
heureusement avec le nucléaire il y a un
deuxième effet qui se coule déjà
l'électricité les communications les
transports tout ça c'est coupé retour à
l'âge de pierre en plus les explosions
créer beaucoup de fumées de poussière
390 millions de tonnes l'air devient
irrespirable toxique pendant plusieurs
semaines le ciel et le soleil sont
obstrués la terre plongée dans le noir
un hiver nucléaire avec des températures
qui baisent devant à 30 degrés dans ces
conditions impossible de faire pousser
le moindre légume la famine fait des
ravages pour autant c'est pas la fin de
l'humanité on a déjà traversé plusieurs
airs glaciaires il y a 115000 ans il
faisait moins 50 degrés en Europe or
avec notre technique d'isolation moderne
ça serait beaucoup plus facile après
tout on est capable de vivre oh mycon en
Russie ou il fait moins 71 en plus
certains pays seraient assez peu touchés
des régions d'Afrique restent très
chaudes avec quasi pas de grandes villes
donc pas de bombe et donc moins de
poussière il y a plus de 5 millions de
villes et de villages dans le monde pas
assez de bombes pour toucher tout le
monde et va trouver tous ceux qui sont
isolés dans la forêt où les déserts il
suffirait d'un million de survivants
pour venir au milliards en moins de 700
ans comment créer une maladie mortelle
il nous faut un virus capable
d'éradiquer l'humanité et contagieux
difficile à soigner avec une longue
période d'incubation comme ça une
personne qui se croise saine continue de
vivre normalement et contamine ses
proches il faut qu'il résiste à la
chaleur et aux UV pour rester collés aux
objets et qu'ils soient volatils pour
être respiré et bien sûr mortel dans
100% des cas disons-le un tel virus
n'existe pas il y a toujours un point
faible le covid a contaminé 760 millions
de personnes mais n'en a tué que 7 1% de
mortalité le virus de l'agrippe
espagnole a fait entre 50 et 100
millions de morts en 1918 mais il est
aujourd'hui moins létal que par le passé
en plusieurs formes de grippe
saisonnière et notre système immunitaire
est devenu plus résistant heureusement
il existe des virus encore inconnus par
exemple ceux de la préhistoire je l'ai
dans le permafrost des scientifiques ont
réussi à en retrouver et aller réactiver
5 nouvelles familles de virus vieux de
48000 ans toujours capable de se
propager si les gaz venaient à fondre
heureusement ils ne sont pas dangereux
pour l'homme ou les animaux du moins
ceux qu'on connaît mais pourquoi
attendre quand on peut nous-mêmes créer
ces virus avec les derniers progrès en
biologie synthétique et génie génétique
on peut absolument tout faire éditer la
RN d'un virus depuis zéro il suffirait
d'inventer une imprimante génomique
spoiler ça existe déjà et vous pourriez
sortir Ébola de votre chambre des
laboratoires le font déjà avec des
fuites très inquiétantes malheureusement
même avec un super virus ça va être
compliqué on le voit avec le jeu plugink
avec l'annonce une pandémie toutes les
îles vont couper leur aéroport et
s'isoler du monde il y en a plus de
11000 qui sont habitées et ça compte des
pays comme Madagascar ou le Japon
détaché des continent autre solution
empoisonner les os c'est le plan de
l'épouvantail dans le film Batman Begins
dans l'histoire le prince Vlad III
l'Empaleur l'a fait en Roumanie en
jetant des corps infestés par la peste
dans des puits on l'utilise encore
aujourd'hui après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale un groupe d'Israël et a voulu
se venger de la Shoah en empoisonnant
l'eau potable de toutes les grandes
villes allemandes Berg ils ont accès à
la vanne principale du centre de
distillation mais il leur manquait le
poison il le récupère auprès d'un
militaire membre du groupe un mélange
d'arsenic et de colle cachés dans des
tubes de dentifrice les renseignements
anglais vont heureusement les arrêter et
tout se rajouter à la mer oui quand tu
bois la tasse à la mer tu bois un peu
d'implantinazzi dilué à l'extrême si on
avait accès à tous les réseaux potables
et à toutes les sources d'eau quelle
serait la toxine la plus efficace déjà
il nous faut une énorme quantité hors
des poisons comme le Novy choc très
puissant sont aussi très difficile à
produire l'une des meilleures options
pourrait être l'arsenic contenu
naturellement dans les sols 1,5 millions
de tonnes disponibles c'est mortel à
partir de 300 mais même à faible dose ça
provoque cancer problème respiratoire et
AVC le poison pourrait se propager dans
les animaux le lait la viande sans même
que nous le sachions puisqu'il n'a ni
goût ni odeur le problème c'est que les
calculs ne sont pas bons l'arsenic est
très difficile à extraire avec quelques
rares gisements le reste étant dispersé
un peu partout dans la croûte terrestre
on a besoin de 2100 tonnes pour tuer
tout le monde impossible de réunir tout
ça utiliser les intelligences
artificielles c'est le scénario de
Terminator nos technologies se
retournent contre nous pour
l'astrophysicien Stéphane Hawking c'est
possible souvenez-vous dans un épisode
de Black Mirror des petits drones en
forme d'abeille sont créés pour
polliniser des fleurs et ainsi remplacer
les vrais abeilles en voie d'extinction
elles se font pirater et tu sur demande
je vais briser tes os je vais boire ton
sang est-ce que c'est faisable pas
vraiment déjà nos intelligences
artificielles sont programmées par des
humains qui leur disent quoi faire elles
sont limitées à ça par exemple on ne
laisserait jamais une nappe piloter tout
seul un drone tueur attendez on l'a déjà
fait
des Turcs ont créé un drone capable de
choisir ses cibles et de tirer sans la
moindre intervention humaine et ce drone
tueur autonome a été utilisé en Libye
pour la première fois en 2020 alors
comment on empêche que la même chose
arrive dans notre société depuis
quelques années on parle d'y avec un
ensemble de règles internationales
définissent ce qui sera interdit de
faire c'est d'ailleurs mon métier le
plus inquiétant serait que les IA
commencent à communiquer entre elles
c'est déjà arrivé en 2017 deux
programmes nommés alice et Bob ont
commencé à discuter ensemble avec un
langage incompréhensible pour un humain
terrifiant dans tous les scénarios
catastrophes la création du nid à
diabolique n'est jamais volontaire elle
accomplit simplement sa tâche et la
comprise de travers c'est le cas dans le
film Avengers l'ère d'ultron ou Iron Man
créer une IA pour garantir la paix dans
le monde problème
Ultron comprend que la guerre est causée
par les hommes et cherche donc à tous
les tuer causer une catastrophe
naturelle il y en a trois qu'on pourrait
facilement provoquer d'abord détourner
un astéroïde pour le faire s'écraser sur
Terre il faudra attendre 2036 au moment
où l'astéroïde Apophis frôlera la Terre
pour le détourner on doit envoyer une
sonde spatiale qui percutera l'astéroïde
à grande vitesse afin de dévier sa
trajectoire une sorte de billard de
l'espace la NASA l'a déjà fait comme en
septembre 2022 la BAC créerait une onde
de choc qui détruirait tout sur son
passage un nuage de débris retomberait
sur la terre sous forme de pluie et de
roche enflammées mais Apophis et trop
petit quelques millions de morts tout au
mieux la MA plus gros ne suffira pas
après tout les dinosaures nyancent pas
survécu si on dit que la poule descend
des Raptors c'est bien que des Raptors
ont survécu pour y évoluer en nos
espèces modernes du coup deuxième
solution noyer la planète en faisant
fondre tous les glaciers 40% de la
population mondiale vit à moins de 100
km des côtes malheureusement il n'y a
pas assez de glace sur terre voici une
carte du monde à son maximum sur merci
cible le niveau des eaux ne montrait que
de 600 mètres et la fonte des glaciers
est entrée longue on aurait le temps de
fuir des côtes reste une dernière
solution le super volcan il y a 75000
ans l'éruption supervolcanique du
Montauban en a failli entraîner
l'extinction de l'humanité il a libéré
2800 kilomètres cubes de cendres et de
lave causant une période glaciaire de 15
à 20 ans il faudrait des dizaines de
milliers de bombes nucléaires pour
obtenir ce résultat 20 super volcans
sont répartis dans le monde et si tous
venaient à entrer en éruption les
conséquences seraient dévastatrices pour
la vie sur Terre mais comment déclencher
leur éruption soit vous injecter
massivement de l'eau du gaz sous
pression dans la chambre magmatique soit
vous enterrer profondément une bombe
nucléaire suffisamment puissante pour
dérégler l'équilibre géologique est-ce
que ça va marcher on l'a jamais testé
pour des raisons évidentes ceci dit on
l'étudie comme un moyen d'atténuer la
violence d'une éruption soit tout
l'inverse de ce qu'on cherche à faire
l'humanité est-elle vraiment éradicale
des chercheurs ont estimé que pour
relancer une population il suffisait de
160 personnes suffisantes pour garantir
une bonne diversité génétique à travers
le temps une information essentielle si
on devait coloniser de nouvelles
planètes mais nous c'est un faux elle
nous arrange pas vraiment il suffit que
0,00
0 0 2% des gens survivent et notre
projet d'éradication tombe à l'eau non
décidément l'humanité semble impossible
à éradiquer à moins que il faudrait
rendre la planète inhabitable c'est déjà
arrivé dans notre histoire la terre a
connu cinq extinctions quasi totale de
la vie par le froid ou par le feu la
plus violente étant celle du perma Trias
échauffement des fonds océaniques baisse
de l'oxygène dans l'eau libération
massive de gaz à effet de serre à cause
de l'éruption des trappes sibériens plus
10 degrés à la surface
96% de la vie n'y a pas survécu avec
notre réchauffement climatique il y a un
truc à faire non on n'allume tous nos
voitures et on fait de grands feux de
forêt pour pouvoir s'auto détruire en
douceur ben même pas selon le GIEC dans
le scénario le plus pessimiste nous
n'atteindrions que plus 4,8 degrés en
100 temps alors oui c'est beaucoup hein
toute cette zone serait inhabitable mais
on pourrait migrer plus au nord toutes
les glaces ayant fondu il restera
toujours à cette terre pour nous
accueillir non nous sommes décidément
des parasites bien tenaces il faut
espérer un emballement à partir de 70
degrés avec des conséquences en chaîne
incontrôlables forêt en flammes ou
séance stérile et terre désertique la
planète n'aurait plus rien de verre
n'est-ce pas tout ce qu'on voulait
éviter dans notre haine des hommes nous
avons détruit ce que nous voulions
sauver nous avons fait de cette carte
postale un enfer pavé de bonnes
intentions
[Musique]